biden begs for help that's the subject
of tonight's waters words do you believe
in karma i do what goes around comes
around we've all seen bad people do bad
things they get away with it for a while
don't they but sooner or later it all
comes back to bite them
well finally the left is reaping what
they sowed every liberal precinct in
america is getting rocked
two hollywood actors in back to back
weeks have dominated the news mired in
massive scandals justice smallett and
alec baldwin both trump-hating
narcissists both reckless liars bringing
shame to their industry one convicted of
a race-baiting hoax the other shot a
woman dead on set both ran to abc news
and cried
[Music]
that's how
he
was talking to a friend and i said i
just want them to find them
but abc didn't save them both interviews
blew up in their faces and now they're
facing national scorn and possible
prison time the media and other liberal
institutions terminally ill and in no
shape to rehab anybody
cnn's top anchor chris cuomo facing his
own sexual misconduct allegations fired
by jeff zucker for cause and cuomo is
going to sue cnn to get the rest of his
contract paid out cnn says it won't pay
so it's about to get ugly with leaks
unable to crack a million viewers in any
hour of the day they may be forced to
put don lemon in cuomo's spot an
unappealing anchor who's also facing a
nasty nasty
sexual assault allegation
cnn doesn't come on in airports anymore
so now we'll know nobody's going to be
watching them
cnn could also lose millions after kyle
rittenhouse takes him to the cleaners
for defamation
[Laughter]
liberal cities turned into war zones
after defund the police and bail reform
12 american cities smashing murder
records so far this year
all these cities run by democrats philly
my hometown
524 homicides
but the radical d.a larry krasner
doesn't see the dead bodies we don't
have a crisis of lawlessness we don't
have a crisis of crime we don't have a
crisis of violence the streets call him
uncle larry because they know larry's
going to let him out
uncle larry soros funded a left-wing
billionaire is buying off da's and
causing a crime wave
and so jen saki blames kovit
smash and grab teams tearing through
cities this has nothing to do with covid
they aren't stealing vaccines
they're costing business millions of
dollars in shutting down shopping
districts before christmas
but aoc says don't believe what you see
with your own eyes
a lot of
these allegations of organized retail
theft they're not actually panning out
like when like these believe it's a
walgreens in california cited it but
what they what the data didn't back in
us
aoc is trying to play you for a fool
jen sachi said at least the byte
administration sending federal support
to deal with these smash and grabs
well we checked and she lied the
national sheriff's association said they
haven't seen any help from the feds the
white house played you for a fool on
immigration too
remember kamala went to guatemala to fix
root causes
so the guatemalan president was asked
how harris has been figuring that out
with him
other than your meeting with kamala
harris in june that's the only one that
that is the only communication you've
had with the bind administration about
illegal immigration
guatemala hasn't heard from kamala since
june
that whole trip was a stunt kamala's
entire vice presidency is a stunt hiring
child actors hiding after afghanistan
and as you know fake laughing
slow down everybody
[Laughter]
can i get a witness
she falls for every hoax too kamala
thought rittenhouse was guilty and
smolette was innocent
the woman has the lowest approval rating
in vp history and her staff's leaking
and jumping ship the resignations just
keep piling up and so does the bad press
a former staffer told the washington
post quote it's clear that you're not
working with somebody who's willing to
do the prep and the work with kamala you
have to put up with a constant amount of
soul-destroying criticism and also her
own lack of self-confidence so you're
constantly sort of propping up a bully
and it's not really clear why
the byte administration's rotting from
the head
joe's toast and the voters know it even
the democrats know it politico spoke to
several democrats and wrote this week
that they're trying to distance
themselves from president biden because
his poll numbers are getting so so bad
the democrat-controlled senate just
passed a republican bill to overturn
joe's vacs mandate for private business
even the media can't help but notice how
bad things really are here's nbc news
throwing a haymaker in the briefing room
the withdrawal from afghanistan over the
summer was widely criticized
there are increasing tensions with china
and taiwan and now you have russian
troops amassing on the border with
ukraine candidate biden campaigned on a
pledge to restore america's credibility
on the world stage on his foreign policy
experience is he living up to that
pledge
sake stammered she had no answers i'm
not even going to air any more of their
spin it's just going to give you a
headache but it's a catastrophe wherever
you turn in liberal america their
education monopoly poisoned by critical
race theory bill clinton's gal pal
galaine maxwell on trial for underage
sex trafficking
michigan with all the mandates clocking
in is the number one state with the
highest coveted case rate media
obviously silent
media is still silent on the black
supremacist ex-con sex offender out on
low bail who murdered six innocent
americans during a christmas parade in
waukesha wisconsin they blamed an suv
then just blacked out the massacre
fox
hit with a christmas crime this week as
a deranged freak burned down our tree
our top-notch security though they
tackled him and the fire department
quickly put out the blaze but of course
the arsonists walked out of jail the
next day because dangerous democrats
have hotwired the laws around here
and the new york times actually wrote
the tree caught on fire
maybe we should blame the bic lighter
but fox was back up with a new tree
within 24 hours
and while fox is fixing problems joe
biden causes problems and then just
blames everybody else now he's begging
the media to help him out
this week the biden white house held
secret meetings with journalists and
begged for better coverage
how bad does a democrat president have
to be doing for him to have to beg
democrats in the media for better spin
joe hasn't the media done enough for you
already buried the laptop ignored the
border and stopped the fact checking
i'm afraid to ask what better coverage
would look like
there might be kids watching at home
biden runs away from reporters and now
he wants them to lie for him
the media's lied about so much already
russia kavanaugh the lab leak surely
none of those reporters would lie on
demand
of course they would
dana milbank washington post as i've
said worst paper in america came out
with this piece quote the media treats
biden as badly or worse than trump
here's proof
i must have missed the media calling
biden a fat white supremacist true
painting trader
but another hack raised his hands and
answered biden's sos call
big economic relief for millions of
americans who have been dealing with
soaring energy prices
cost of the pump
finally easing up with the national
average for a gallon of regular falling
to three dollars and 35 cents the lowest
since october just look at that
that was esteemed economist don lemon
celebrating the price of gas going down
seven cents
after gas went up over a dollar since
biden's inauguration
not to be outdone more hacks stood up
the question is why don't people want to
hear the good news for a change is that
what we need to to hear when something
good is happening you said you know that
people are not picking up on the good
stuff i believe that that's because the
media is not portraying him as a winner
they are minimizing what he is doing
when the chips are down americans are
going to understand that if republicans
take control of this country again we
are done as a country believe it
with friends like dana don whoopi and
joy who needs enemies
keep telling americans you're great
keep saying how great things are see
what happens in the midterms
everything on the left is collapsing
across the board the press can't rescue
you this time the press helped you get
into this mess and they're in just as
much trouble as you
the press and all of their decrepit
institutions conspired to knock trump
out and foist an unvetted empty suit on
this country and the country knows it
and the country's paying for it and now
it's payback time hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else